we're going to begin with another
troubling incident ending in a black
man's death
following an encounter with police a
protest was held yesterday where it
happened this time in
rochester new york daniel prude was his
name he died of suffocation after
officers put a hood
over his head while arresting him now
this time there is body cam video and we
have to tell you up front it is graphic
yeah that's right prude was naked and
suffering from a mental health episode
when police arrived on the scene they
say the hood was necessary because he
was spitting at them
and they were concerned about the
coronavirus this happened back on march
23rd but the video is only
just released now erika duncan is in
rochester forest rica good morning to
you
trouble in case here what more do we
know
good morning and so much more to learn
about this case he was a resident of
chicago that was visiting rochester
to see family now it was his brother who
made the phone call
to police because they said that his
brother was acting strange and this was
about three
hours after his brother had been
released from the hospital
but the family says what happened next
was unfathomable
a warning the video we're about to air
is very
disturbing get on the ground
get on the ground police body camera
video shows rochester officers ordering
a naked daniel prude to lie on the
ground in the early hours of march 23rd
don't move all right man
just don't move police put the 41 year
old's hands behind his back
and handcuffed him he was like lifting
the garbage can
i saw him like running across he almost
got hit by a car too
the video shows prude yelling and
spitting give me your gun
give me your gun i need as he sits
completely naked and handcuffed on the
ground
police put a white spit hood over his
head
they flipping over i mean that
god bless y'all later an officer appears
to
push poot's head into the pavement
[Music]
he says he has corona
you good man prude stopped breathing and
emts performed cpr as he was taken to
the hospital
where he was put on life support prude
died seven days later
the medical examiner ruled his death a
homicide caused by complications of
asphyxia in the setting of physical
restraint
excited delirium and acute pcp
intoxication
which could have explained his erratic
behavior a whole bloody calculated
murder
daniel prude's brother joe is calling
for the police officers involved
to be held responsible for his brother's
death
you hear him don't kill me
that was a sign right there for y'all to
let up but they didn't
they continue to apply pressure more
than five months after prude's death
none of the officers have been fired or
disciplined i know that there is a
there's rhetoric that is out there that
this is a cover-up this is not
a cover-up the city's police chief
insisted
this is an ongoing investigation and the
mayor said the case is in the state's
hands according to the law
put into place after the death of eric
garner
unfortunately it has taken some time
and i sympathize with the family because
i too
when i saw the video was very disturbed
joe proud says he called the police to
help his brother
but instead of assistance the police
took his brother's life
you're here for the owner to protect and
serve not to protect
and kill prude's family says they intend
to file a wrongful death lawsuit against
the city of rochester the mayor here
says she's working with the attorney
general's office
to look further into this case the
attorney general's office put out a
statement yesterday in part
that said that the prosecutions and
investigations unit
is looking into this we did reach out to
the five or the several officers rather
reportedly
involved in this case and have not heard
back yet
anthony all right jerica thank you